this video is sponsored by brilliant and
that sponsorship is relevant to what
we're talking about today divesting in
fossil fuels campaigning for divestment
you divested their funding divest 60 to
90 million dollars to divest the
University full divest
ums the divestments saying divesting and
disassociating you have probably heard
of the divestment movement if you've not
this is the belief that universities
should divest or sell their assets in
fossil fuel producing companies you see
big universities will often have complex
financial investments designed to take
their large pot of money and make a
bigger pot of money the excess being
used to finance research and operations
historically some of those Investments
have been in companies like Exxon shell
and so on companies whose primary
business model is extracting and selling
fossil fuels the use of which is the
primary driver of anthropogenic climate
change so starting in about 2011
campaigners have been asking
universities to be more particular in
where they put their money and sell or
divest their Assets in fossil fuel
companies the idea being that
universities should not be doing harm to
the planet by providing money to the
industry that can then be used to
finance further extraction and burning
of fossil fuels the campaign has gone
from strength to strength as of the time
of recording 100 UK universities have
pledged to completely divest from the
fossil fuel industry and globally almost
1500 institutions representing nearly 39
trillion dollars of assets have publicly
pledged to some level of fossil fuel
divestment for those of us who believe
that universities should not be
contributing to the largest problem of
our time this is great news
but the relationship between
universities and the fossil fuel
industry isn't a one-way Street while
universities are no longer investing in
fossil fuels that industry is still
investing in universities in the form of
sponsoring research my name is United
kashtan I'm now a third year PhD student
in Stanford's Earth system science
department my PhD research focuses on
mostly the health implications of fossil
fuel use in the home I really got
involved with this fossil fuel
dissociation movement kind of by
accident
last May the now dean of the door School
of sustainability told a New York Times
Reporter that the school would be open
to accepting fossil fuel money and that
sort of set off a little Firestorm of
outrage on a group just like a WhatsApp
group chat I was a part of surprised
dismayed and outraged about about how a
new school of sustainability could be
taking fossil fuel money given the
very very long track record of
disinformation by these companies and
this is not exclusive to universities
other institutions such as museums have
accepted donations from the fossil fuel
industry sometimes even sponsoring
exhibitions on climate change I'm sure I
don't need to tell you that if a company
like shell responsible for the emission
of huge quantities of carbon dioxide and
thus directly responsible for a changing
climate is paying for an exhibition on
climate change there's a conflict of
interest the end result of what is being
sponsored may be altered by the nature
of the sponsorship but there are less
obvious effects aside from direct
influence if a company is sponsoring a
museum or a university it is engaging in
advertising that's at least in part why
they do it and if a company is
sponsoring a school of sustainability
then the company is specifically trying
to associate itself with sustainability
trying to boost its green credentials if
the actions of the company do not align
with those credentials however then we
have a term for it green washing make an
eco-conscious public view the company
more positively while not actually
changing any of its potentially harmful
activities extending the length of time
that those activities take place over we
see this very frequently for example
Coca-Cola sponsoring ineffective plastic
cleanups rather than reducing the amount
of plastic waste they produce yennai is
part of a group of people that question
the role of fossil fuel companies
sponsoring research at universities and
specifically his University Stanford the
group calls for universities to take a
step further than divestment
dissociation what is the difference
between divestment and dissociation in
our context the way that we're using it
divestment is not investing the
endowment in a particular sector be it
safe fossil fuel companies dissociation
is not accepting research grants and
gifts from a particular industry or a
particular class of companies in this
case fossil fuel companies for instance
as an example Harvard has at least
announced that it is divesting against
endowment it's still though taking money
for research from fossil fuel companies
why do you think the universities should
not be accepting this money what are the
downsides to accepting the money if it's
a fair question uh I mean the one liner
is because it delays climate actions and
actually obstructs the mission of the of
the school which is to foster a more
sustainable world we know and there's
this new paper out in science
documenting exxon's knowledge of climate
projections very accurate projections
and then disinformation around climate
so Exxon and many of these other fossil
fuel companies have been either directly
or through the American petroleum
Institute sowing disinformation about
climate so they're not sort of honest
Partners in in the fight against climate
change being able to use the prestige of
of these universities to argue say to
lawmakers and to the public that these
companies are actually acting in good
faith when they are not it diverts time
talent and money away from more
promising Solutions so for instance if a
company is funding a climate it carbon
capture and storage project all those
talented grad students working hard and
being underpaid are working hard on
being underpaid there and not somewhere
else that opportunity cost is pretty
large as well I think the upsides to
universities accepting this money are
pretty obvious research is performed
that would not otherwise be performed
giving us a better understanding of the
natural world though I'll come back to
that point later by the end of this
video I want you to have formed an
opinion on dissociation and I'll share
mine with you but in order to do that I
think we need some additional context
and that's where we run into the biggest
problem that I had in writing this video
a lack of transparency from universities
in where their funding comes from I wish
I could tell you what percentage of
research is financed by fossil fuel
companies or better yet what percentage
of climate research is financed by
fossil fuel companies but that
information is scattered across
thousands of documents many of which are
private to universities so here's what I
can tell you according to to government
figures in the UK 55 of all research is
funded by the private sector it's
interesting to note though that over 70
percent of all research and development
is actually performed by the private
sector higher education institutions
only perform about 22 percent of all
research that remainder being by private
non-profits University Research is 62
publicly funded with UK businesses only
contributing about four percent of all
funding so this discussion then focuses
on how a fraction of a percent of all
researchers performed it's not like the
dissociate movement is trying to shut
down all research but that's about as
much as I can say on a growth scale now
I have connections to two UK
universities I did my undergrad and
Masters at Oxford and my PhD at Exeter
and I thought in the absence of more
comprehensive data across the board I
could look at these two as two case
studies appropriately as well because
they're both very large players on the
climate research scene Oxford has a vast
endowment that is invested pretty
broadly but I'm happy to say that in
April 2020 the university announced that
it was divesting from the fossil fuel
industry and has since decreased the
percentage of its fund invested in
non-renewable energy from 8.5 to just
0.6 percent further it actively invests
its Fund in climate Solutions so top
marks yet as far as I'm aware
components of the universe
let's not get into the complicated
structure of Oxford University still
accept funding from fossil fuel
producers a report found that between
2015 and 2020 the university accepted at
least 8.2 million pounds in research
grants and at least 3.7 million pounds
in donations from fossil fuel producers
notable recipients of that money being
the engineering and Earth Science
departments the earth science department
had a research income of 8.5 million
pounds per year at the start of that
period so at most fossil fuel money
could represent 10 of the Department's
income though of course looking at the
spread of donations amongst other
departments the actual number is going
to be much lower I would Hazard a guess
at two percent of the Department's
income as a brief aside the Oxford Smith
School of Enterprise and the environment
does not accept money from the fossil
fuel industry and neither does the
famous Oxford Martin School more on them
at the end so what about Exeter in
December 2019 the university announced
that it was ceasing investment in the
fossil fuel industry and has since Seoul
their existing Assets in the sector
good job however it did just sign a
five-year research agreement with shell
based on carbon sequestration and
continuing a previous research
relationship seemingly without
consulting the student body or academics
I wasn't able to find any more specific
information on what kind of percentage
of research income this represented
based on what I've learned about these
two universities then fossil fuel money
represents a small percentage of all
earth science research and is tied to
specific projects in extra for example
burying carbon in the ground one example
from Oxford was the research of organic
carbon deposition in the geological
record that means finding oil Rich rocks
and at this point I want to return to
something that I said earlier about the
advantages of accepting this money
because what research is being performed
that's in hypothetical world where we
weren't accepting fossil fuel money
would not exist there is abundant
evidence including a recent paper in
nature climate change documenting that
centers that are funded by fossil fuel
companies or that receive fossil fuel
funding are sort of systematically more
favorable towards fossil fuels including
natural gas they are not going to fund
research that is going to be
existentially threatening to their
business model and in this we see a
direct parallel to another debate that
happened some decades ago in 1953 it was
demonstrated that smoking caused cancer
this was actually hardly surprising in
the 1930s Nazi scientists had shown the
same results but they were ignored
because you know Nazis but this time the
signs stuck and the tobacco industry was
labeled as a danger to Public Health
amid dozens of lawsuits the industry
responded with a decades-long running
campaign of denial disinformation and
deflection this involved funding
research and researchers to assist them
in creating doubt in the science
eventually however after significant
discussion research institutions turned
their backs on accepting funding from
the tobacco industry the British medical
journal no longer accepts research
funded by the industry and organizations
such as cancer research UK publicly call
on University please do not accept such
funding it's interesting to note by the
way that Oxford University has a blanket
ban on accepting money from the tobacco
industry due to the quote great harm to
Public Health that it causes yet the
health impacts of burning fossil fuels
are just as significant as those caused
by the tobacco industry let alone the
environmental impact of course one is a
recreational activity the other one
underpins our economy for now but does
that really matter when you're
determining who to accept money from but
that's not the only parallel and this is
where I can offer something of a
personal perspective because accepting
money accepting sponsorship on specific
conditions with a close association
between me and the sponsor and
constituting a not insignificant part of
income
that's exactly how educational YouTubers
operate I said at the start that this
video was sponsored by brilliant and
they are a long-term sponsor that I am
very happy to be working with but why
this I think is the core issue with the
dissociate movement it comes down to who
are you happy to accept money from and
why personally I am happy to work with
brilliant because our values align we
have the same end goal of educating
people and helping them understand the
natural world because I want to live in
a world where people are scientifically
literate I am very particular with who I
choose to work with as sponsors because
my ability to do my job is closely tied
to how my audience perceives me if I
were to accept money from a company that
was known for negative actions in a
field that I frequently make videos
about that undermines my credibility
frankly my authority and this is
something shared with universities and
why I think the dissociate movement has
started here rather than anywhere else I
think universities are special though I
don't know I think museums have a
similar stature here in that they are to
the extent you know we still have public
in these kinds of Institutions they are
these trustworthy sources of
understanding of the world and of policy
prescriptions as well and so people look
to them both as sort of examples of in
some cases even ethical leadership and
and certainly certainly knowledge of of
the world and what should be done about
about global problems and so I think
these should be held to a higher
standard even depending on your point of
view we are talking about money that's
going towards projects that are either
extending the lifespan of fossil fuels
or are allowing that industry to take on
a new role in some low-carbon future and
while we are talking about funding for a
range of projects including renewable
energy they are all undeniably
associated with an industry that not
only is directly responsible for the
climate crisis but has in previous
decades acted in bad faith though to
speak somewhat as Devil's Advocate
should we really be judging an industry
for Its Behavior decades ago when it's
offering to finance and develop a
technology carbon sequestration negative
emissions that's widely regarded as
being an essential part of a net zero
future this is a complex topic we are
talking about a vast amount of money
being available at a critical time for
climate and for decarbonization Action
across a wide range of projects while
you can probably guess what my opinion
is I am not unaware of arguments on the
other side of the counter arguments to
be honest I'm not certain there is a
simple answer to the question should any
Universities accept any money from the
fossil fuel industry just as there's no
simple answer to the question who should
universities accept money from it's
going to depend on lots of factors not
least where the money gets used but if
you pressed me for a simple binary
answer to the question then especially
considering the small percentage of
research that we're talking about here I
would say no universities should not
accept coal and oil and gas money if you
agree with that absolute stance then if
you're a student I'd recommend looking
up how your University is financing
research and look up the dissociate
movement itself the international sort
of umbrella organization is called
fossil free research and they've got a
great website where you can get involved
and they've got chapters now
proliferating at universities all over
the world certainly the English-speaking
world and I think beyond that would be a
great place to get started in fact if
you're a student at Cambridge
specifically then the university
recently delayed a vote on whether to
dissociate from the fossil fuel industry
or not make your voice heard on this
well you still can the vote's probably
going to happen sometime this Lent turn
but to give a more complex answer and an
answer to the broader question of who in
a climate crisis should universities be
accepting research money from we can
look to some guidance published by the
Oxford Martin School in 2018 the school
published principles for climate
conscious investment three criteria that
if met indicate a sponsor relationship
with a company would not contribute to
the climate crisis those criteria for
the sponsor being a credible commitment
to net zero emissions with a special
emphasis on offsetting having a workable
business model in that scenario and
having actionable targets for the next
few years we should hold universities to
a high standard and just as I have a set
of internal criteria when deciding who
to work with as a sponsor I think these
are excellent criteria for universities
they don't evaluate the direct impact
what the money is being used for but
instead the secondary the associative
effects which I would argue are more
important if a company any company were
to meet these criteria then I think from
a climate perspective universities
should be happy to accept their
financing if shell were to turn around
tomorrow and completely overhaul their
business model such that they met these
three criteria then yeah I think
universities should be okay with
accepting their money but in Practical
terms as an imperfect solution to a
complex problem these criteria flat out
exclude fossil fuel producers from
financing research and so I agree with a
few caveats with the dissociate movement
the question is do you based on this
video what do you think let me know your
take in the comments now at this point
my job is very easy because this is
normally where I would tell you who has
sponsored this video and why I think he
would like them but I've already done
that brilliant.org is an educational
website and Associated app that teaches
you about Concepts in maths science and
computer science in bite-sized chunks
the core principle of brilliant being
learning by doing with lots of
interactive exercises brilliant and I
have happily worked together for several
years now because we are trying to
accomplish the same end goal we are
trying to give people a better toolkit
to understand the universe in my case
that's through statistics and through
atmospheric science in their case it's
through programming chemistry biology
astrophysics you get the idea expanding
your understanding of stem subjects is
fun and it's rewarding that's hopefully
why you watch these videos but doing so
in a more rigorous way for example with
brilliant gives you access to skills
that are incredibly valuable in other
areas of your life whether you're a
student learning about Mechanics for the
first time and would like an alternative
resource to draw on to help you in the
classroom or someone who has dabbled in
programming and would like to learn more
about neural networks for your job
really is an amazing beautifully
Illustrated Interactive Learning tool to
get started for free check out
brilliant.org Simon Clark click the link
in the description the first 200 people
to do so will not only get access to
expertly written courses across a range
of subjects from high school to graduate
school level but also get 20 off an
annual subscription that's brilliant.org
Simon Clark with thanks to brilliant for
sponsoring this video and for being well
brilliant
I really hope that as a result of this
video you have been able to form your
own opinion about the dissociate
movement and whether you agree or
disagree with me let me know down there
in the comments I'd like to encourage a
debate on this thanks must go to yanai
for being so generous with his time he's
a PhD student I know how precious their
time is so thank you yanai if you'd like
to learn more about the dissociate
movement please do check out the links
in the description
fossilfreeresearch.com thanks Mr also go
to these lovely people look up here
these are my executive producers on
patreon.com forward slash simonoxvis
these are people who support me every
month and help me make bigger and better
videos and in return they get access to
the patreon feed with Early Access to
videos bonus content including a monthly
behind the scenes Vlog and at the
executive producer tier thanks in the
video credits if that all sounds good to
you if you would like to help me make
bigger and better videos then please do
check out the link for the patreon in
the description and that just leads me
to say thank you so much for watching if
you enjoyed the video please do pop it a
like and please do share it with people
who you think may be interested in this
campaign if you'd like some more
recommended viewing from me then here's
a couple of videos up here that just
leads me to say thank you for watching
I'll see you in the next one